I'm Pete söderling I'm the founder of
data Council and did a community fund
and thank you for joining us this summer
in our new series we've been shooting
for episodes new episodes every other
Thursday and just as a way to keep
engage with the community and to bring
them content and thoughts from top folks
behind open source data projects so
today I'm really excited to have Drew
van in here who's both a co-founder and
the chief product officer of Fishtown
analytics I drew I have my DB t-shirt on
so for those who don't know Fishtown is
the main company behind the development
of DBT the data build tool and so Drew's
here and just to introduce drew drew has
a background in computer science he's
worked at a variety of startups over the
years in data engineering data analytics
type of capacities and so Drew were
super excited to have you thanks for for
jumping on with us yeah thanks for
having me on Pete I'm a longtime
listener first-time caller been
attending data Council events for the
lifetime Fishtown analytics so happy to
be here thanks for having me
awesome awesome well yeah thank you
so drew something interesting I
discovered on the Fishtown website I
just wanted to start with this this this
is a quote analytics engineering is the
data transformation work that happens
between loading data into warehouse and
analyzing it DBT allows anyone
comfortable with SQL to own that
workflow so so talk to me about what is
DBT how do you like you can unpack that
statement however you'd like there's
there's a lot going on there but let's
start with what is DBT sure
so DBT is you know we've got a punchy
tagline for it it's all about doing the
data modeling work that happens which
means sort of like ingesting data into
data warehouse and then eventually the
other end reporting on it and one of the
big changes we've seen take place in the
analytics ecosystem over the past you
know say five or so years is that
there's a shift from sort of all-in-one
BI tools that will adjust data you know
transform it and report on it to sort of
like a maple say an unbundling of these
tools and you get sort of dedicated data
loading tools you get data
transformation tools which is kind of
where DBT lives and also reporting tools
like say you know looker mode analytics
tempo etc and so we kind of identified
you know say four plus years ago was
that the data warehouse is really
powerful and they're actually a great
way to do all this sort of like encoding
of business logic that is required to do
any sort of real analytics and you could
do a lot work in sequel it's super
accessible to anyone with the sequel
background or knowledge of how to write
sequel so DBT is at its core Apache 2
license to open source software where
you can define what we call data models
in sequel files that specify some
transformation and then DBT itself is
able to manage the dependencies between
these sequel files and sort of help you
build relations in a database in
dependency order so you might have you
know events that we're all up to pay to
use that roll up sessions
DBT will order those paralyze things of
necessary and take your sequel select
statements persist in the databases
tables or views at a high level and
would you say that the the rise of DBT
has been sort of in in parallel of the
this transformation from ETL to ELT this
is a sort of something that's being
commonly spoken about now in the data
engineering world how do you see DBT its
relation to this transformation to
so-called ELT yeah I mean very much so
the the great thing that ELT approaches
get you is sort of optionality when you
land broad data in a data warehouse you
have a whole universe of possibilities
of how you want to reshape that data
sort of in the database and you have a
lot more people that can
actually do that work so the ETL
workflow where you sort of transforming
data as its extracted midstream if
there's a certain you know kind of
subset of people who can access those
types of tools and it means that all the
logic is sort of locked up and sort of a
maybe Brian Terry tool there's the ship
take ELT means that you can have an
extraction loading process that's kind
of like dumb if you will just give me
the raw data and then you're free to
adjust your business logic as your
business changes or as you learn more
about the data so there's actually a
whole lot to talk about it as far as you
know why you want to do this
transformation work in the data
warehouse instead of outside of it but
at the highest level landings like raw
unmodified source data in your data
warehouse just gives you a ton more
flexibility in the types of
transformations you can build and who
can build them and how frequently you
can change them and does DBT is DBT
opinionated about the difference between
a data Lake and a data warehouse or for
the purposes of this conversation will
we've using the terms interchangeably
let's set some ground rules yeah so
they're they're like a handful of words
that are poisoned in my mind they are
like Skiba schema means absolutely
nothing
absent a whole lot of context and maybe
like TFA store warehouse we you know we
work a lot with what I would call data
warehouses like red ship snowflake
bigquery we also have built in DBT
plug-ins for spark and presto and for
many of these tools there are ways to
address data whether it lives in
physical storage on a cluster or in safe
blob file storage like s3 or TCS
whatever and so to us you know we care
about being able to address the data in
sequel just for our purposes we say that
that's a data warehouse and we care less
about if the data store in s3 or on a
you know EBS volume on a wrench of
cluster because you know take their in
stripped case you can address data in
the database you could also address data
in s3
Sonique redshift data leak is it
different than like did spectrum
different than at the end that respect
we don't think it's an incredibly useful
distinction for where DBT operates in
the stack as long as you're it's equal
to address and transform it like duties
pretty happy well suffice it to say that
in this whole move from ETL to ELT it
seems to me that one of the core
concepts is the ability to shift a lot
of the transformational data processing
to the data source itself the data Lake
the data warehouse which means that you
don't have to have extremely structured
data being dumped into that source in
the first place so whether you call it a
data Lake data warehouse or whatever it
seems to me that the magic of DBT and
its place in the ecosystem is inverting
some of that transform process and
giving you the power to do the
transforms on a big heap of poorly
defined or loosely managed data and that
seems to be the magic of DBT is that
accurate
yeah I think that's spot-on you know we
we see the advent are really the rise of
dedicated data loading tools like v
train and stitch which just have no
context about how you want to do your
reporting and they're gonna they're
gonna load what we call source conformed
data and your your data warehouse so
it's like the exact representation for
the data source and then if you think
about things in like an air flow
capacity where maybe you were rolling
your own ETL it feels a little bit
different like you do have an option in
doing the data loading to store changing
the shape of the data and maybe
combining or aggregating data sets the
problem is you as a data engineer might
not have the full context for how the
company wants to analyze this data in
the future and when you start like say
aggregating data or maybe thermo-boy
information that you don't think is
valuable like maybe it's not valuable
today but the business changes like
pretty rapidly and so you're very much
right this shift that's really powered
by like affordable scalable data
warehouses is that you just land source
data into the data warehouse and then
you have sort of a dedicated role of
people who we call analytics engineers
that sit at the intercept
of you know database optimization and
query tuning but also deep context about
the business and you sort of empowered
these people to understand what types of
analyses need to be done and what work
needs to be done to get the data like
the source data into the format where
you can actually power those analyses it
sort of lets everyone you know find
their spot in the data stack where they
can be most effective and it doesn't ask
people to do you know too many things
all at the same time
ok so drew I just wanted to call out
before we go further that we have over
60 people from all over the world on the
show so far just super exciting and as
you know one of the format wrinkles that
we're playing with here at DC Thursdays
is to allow the ability of the audience
listeners to ask questions midstream so
we're not saving questions for the end I
just want to encourage the audience and
listeners to feel free to type your
questions into the YouTube chat and
we'll be taking them as we go
interspersed through the conversation so
before we we start that true I just
wanted to acknowledge that I probably
met you in 2016 or 17 when DBT was
really nascent and it was a baby little
project and I wanted to touch on this
notion of the analytics engineer because
at that time you guys had not sort of
hitched your horse to this notion of the
analytics engineer you probably didn't
know exactly how that was going to
emerge you probably didn't know how the
data ecosystem was going to emerge and
so at that time it felt to me like DBT
was this really interestingly weird
in-between tool that almost didn't have
a place in the world it didn't seem to
be acknowledged by the data engineering
community as such they were all talking
about Africa and you know ETL to
traditional ETL and other things and DBT
was this kind of scriptable command line
data transformation Swiss Army knife
thing that seemed to allow non data
engineers to
do data engineering type things and I
think it was a little bit confusing to
the community at the time on since then
you've obviously grown up you've gotten
big community adoption you figured out
how to continue to articulate what it is
you do what your value prop is and
you've landed on this this notion of the
analytics engineer so talk to me about
the analytics engineer and sort of how
that's meaningful and and how you see
that role emerging and how it's slightly
different than a traditional data
engineer sir you know I just want to I
would have validate the thing that you
said which was that back in 2016 at like
Brooklyn Naval Yard data council you
know I I spoke to felt like a hundred
people about what we were trying to do
it was something like oh interesting
cool here's what we're doing an airflow
and it's like ha but you're right it's
very much an it's an it's a new role and
organization it requires a blend of
different skills that you know we think
a lot of people had before but there
wasn't a name to affixed to it and I
think what's happened over the past like
four years is not it's really just like
a recognition of the fact that this is a
good way of organizing work and have
like a good skill set that people can
really like get into and grow in over
time so um okay and I oppose this your
actual question was about analogous
engineering but what specifically what
what is it what is it I think about how
do you see it about evolving else we
have a modern data era so yeah that a
powerfully thing happens when you get
data addressable in a data warehouse
that's you know addressable a sequel it
means that anybody who can write sequel
can both write and understand the
business logic required to sort of
operate on that data so kind of what
happened historically was you didn't
have a dedicated part of your stack that
was specifically for data modeling you
either did it as a part of ingestion or
you did it kind of like at recording
time like just-in-time data modeling
that looks like these really gnarly sub
queries that you copy and paste between
every report
you ever make and you know in either
case there drawbacks take the reported
case sure okay like I'm gonna make
everyone on this club really upset
what's an active user in your in your
company it's generally not an easy
question to answer and it usually is
mired and like well we had deleted users
we have internal users we don't want to
count
we've got testing users that we
identified by their like VPN IP address
and so if you actually want to get a
number right there's a lot of logic to
CRA's into this it might change over
time and so the goal for the analytics
engineering profession is to sort of
take all of that business logic and
figure out how to represent it as you
know what we call data models in a data
warehouse I mean that's a very tactical
version of it the higher level answer is
like these are the people responsible
for creating organizing and
disseminating knowledge within their
organizations so the mechanism we see
them employeeís data warehouse isn't
sequel but like it's actually much
broader thing just like you know typing
data models all day so you know where
did it come from it was the belief that
you just can't live with all these
different reports for your copy and
pasting critical business logic between
all of them things get out of stake
people on different numbers there it's
slow because you're like at you know
query time kept recalculating you know
what a session is out of pageviews or
something like that and it's things mmm
you have a lot more options to do a good
job when you make this a dedicated part
of the stack and so the analytics
engineers sort of lived in and around
the data warehouse and they think a lot
about what the data is that's coming in
and what reporting is happening on top
of it and really what the data model is
that should power the question-answering
for the whole business and would you say
that would you say that an analytics
engineer is a functional replacement for
a data engineer and some teams do some
teams have one and not the other or do
they coexist together in some cases like
how do you see that yeah you know we
fixed our analytics for you know the
majority of our early history say like
first
for four years we did a lot of
consulting and we would implement DBT
and it's a big part of why I think we
struck a nerve with analysts it's
because like we were doing the work and
we've built DBT to help us do the work
and so as a part of consulting we got to
see every different data stack and
organization practice you can imagine we
saw teams where they had 40 data
engineers and one analyst we saw teams
where there were 40 analysts and one day
to engineer and the reality is like you
kinda want to be somewhere in the middle
and the cool thing about promoting
analytics engineering as a practice is
it lets each of these different data
rolls kind of focus on what they're good
at so the data engineering case is
interesting we should talk about it but
the really kind of queer one is the data
science use case where every data
scientist talks about how difficult it
is to get clean data to actually like
analyze and they shouldn't necessarily
be the ones that are doing all the heavy
lifting in the data warehouse to sort of
ETL data and transform it in a way that
it's clean and ready for you know
reporting or data science whatever it is
and then only after like you know a
whole lot of front-loaded work can they
actually do some sort of meaningful
analysis the really cool thing about
having a separate analytics engineering
function is that it's your job to create
you know clean well tested data sets and
the data warehouse the power both data
science and same or business
intelligence type use cases it means
everyone's kind of operating off the
same data so that's what example where
analytics engineering let's kind of data
scientists downstream of the data you
know focus on on what they're excellent
at on the sort of ingestion side you
know the advent of Analects engineering
does not mean that data engineering is
useless it just means that you know show
me a data engineer that's really happy
like building data models for business
users and it'll be an interesting
conversation that looks to be with them
it's not just if they don't do it it's
just that there's you're at this
intersection of like deeply technical
problems and you know domain knowledge
that you might not have or there might
not be readily accessible to you and
from what we've seen MIDI data engineers
are
power to go work with those like domain
experts and understand like what
actually is the thing you need what's
the question you need to answer in how
do we work backwards to a data model
that can power it for you so you know
just in sum what we see is data
engineers focus on infrastructure like
platform stuff
building custom ETL when it's warranted
necessary reporting like monitoring
performance tuning all this stuff it's a
little more like platform or deeply
technical or requires like an
understanding of you know compression
hit algorithms on redshift or things
like that
and less of less of the transformational
less of the transformation work right
and so you know we can talk about this
too but what are the great things about
DBT is it it allows you to build
abstractions in a data warehouse and
bring other software engineering
concepts into analytics and frequently
we find that data engineers are
incredibly helpful in kind of teaching
the analysts on their team like here's
why you want to build an abstraction
over what a user is here's why you don't
want to repeat it multiple times and
every report that you make or here's how
to think about modularity and break down
this one really big table that's hard to
grapple with into smaller tables that
will kind of compose well together I
don't um well let's go to some questions
from the listeners here so first
question is from feeds and they're
asking what are your thoughts we need to
do ETL to deal with PII data masking an
optimization are examples how would be
LT fit that use case yeah it's for your
question any of these privacy and
security questions like your mileage
varies based on the nature of PII and
like regulations but what we've done
works well for most organizations is
like locking down access to the source
data so that it's only accessible to the
people who actually need to process it
say analytics engineers and from there
there are a number of different general
tactics or database specific function
that you can employ to mask PII do one
way hash antics like that and in fact a
lot of people point to DBT is a really
helpful way for them to like tag columns
that contain PII such that if someone
requests like please delete my
information you are able to sort of see
the provenances like okay I've got this
data point what are all the places we
use it downstream how does it all map
together and can I can I delete it can i
hash it and things like that so you do
the thing I would say is like DBT
doesn't take a strong stance on how you
model your data it just gives you the
tools to do it yourself so I'd rather
have that ability and have to answer the
question of like how what's the right
answer for my organization and my needs
then sort of not have this as a discrete
layer of the stack I I think the ETL
case is pretty interesting
I do get how it'd be compelling to just
like not sync that data in the first
place the other thing I'd say is like I
think a lot of a lot of the tools out
there so maybe someone can correct me
from wrong but I think five-strand in
particular might have the ability to
mask certain PII columns and ingestion
time so you know the answer might be
it's a little bit of both you're gonna
want to not collect data that you've no
business analyzing that you don't want
your warehouse in the first place like
credit card numbers and things like that
but if there is like say PII like an
email address and you mask it
DBT gives you an opportunity to write
that transformation to do the masking
and make sure that you know exactly
where that data point flows through in
the rest of your data stack in that
regard just to be clear
DBT supports complex multi-step
transformations on data so you generate
your own dag if I'm not mistaken and you
give the users the ability to sort of
manage manipulate and understand complex
structures and layers of transformation
throughout the data warehouse is that
correct so in that respect like you said
you'd be able to track
PII on the ingestion ah yeah and on the
output and because DBT is structured in
both as a collaborative tool for your
whole team to use and in a way that
supports a clear notion of like what
transformations are happening at each
step in the process based on its tag you
have visibility into all of these things
and you also have the guarantee that you
could transform your data consistently
from one form to the other every single
time just by running running the dag is
that correct yeah that's totally right
all of DB T's models are a tenant and
they can depend on other models which
means that you can rerun any part of
your dag whenever your logic changes or
as you receive new source data the other
really you know compelling part but DBT
was talking about here is DBT is built
in like testing and documentation
capabilities so a DBT model is a sequel
select statement that defines a
transformation and then you can write a
test on top of that model that's more or
less a sequel select statement or a sort
of UML configuration that asserts that
something's true of the data so if for
instance you have a an email column that
you think is supposed to be always
hashed maybe it's a blend of different
you know identity inputs that all feed
into like a user's table you can say
like test that this column only contains
md5 hashes maybe a simple way to do that
is like check for an @ symbol and you
can kind of encode that as a an
assertion about your data and DBT DBT
can then alert you if you receive new
data that is not hashed the reality is
just like there's too many tables and 20
columns for you to hold all of these
assumptions about like reality in your
head and it's better to document them by
writing a test and be alerted if they
don't hold so obviously there's there's
obviously a lot of things that DBT can
do um I wanted to go to another question
here because you touched on sort of the
quality of data Martin hey Martin is
asking related to previous guests Abe
Dhruva you know the author of great
expectations
was here talking about data quality on
the other hand DBT has a powerful set of
data quality tooling
any word on the possible integration of
great expectations and DBT yeah we think
Abe and the green expectations team are
one awesome and - very clever it's a
great name great expectations we it's
something that we've kicked her out a
little bit I think I actually met Abe at
the last step in Cisco data Council
event and we had a chat in the hallway
about what it could look like it's a
it's an off requested integration from
people in the DBT community so no
concrete plans to implement them but
there is a lot of overlap and I think
they work well together so I'd be
excited to figure out a way that we can
get the - speaking together a little
more tightly got it so um you're a
product guy in addition to being an
engineer and you're running product at
Fishtown on that note I'm curious like
what is the big vision for DBT like
where do you see this going from a
product standpoint Flavian jumped in in
the chat and asked that as well and I
might be curious to hear your thoughts
on the bigger vision for DBT yeah so you
know we're we're a mission-driven
company our our missions front and
center efficient analytics comm and
we've got a page that our numerate
solver values and so just like very
plainly reading from the mission right a
mission to empower analysts to create
and organize create and disseminate
organizational knowledge and the kind of
big idea there you don't would you
understand what DBT is then how we're
empowering these analytics engineers you
kind of get a sense for tactically what
we want to do with DBT but when you take
a few steps back the idea is just that
there's you know the most innovative
organizations in the world are using
data today to make decisions and the
pace at which data is collected
it's just accelerating for like every
modern organization and so trying to
make sense of it becomes harder and
harder and more valuable
so you know we we talk about the world
in terms of like data models and data
testing and documentation but really at
a high level we're trying to do is help
folks organize the knowledge that their
businesses command and make it
accessible to different people trying to
answer questions so they can move the
business forward so that way you know
you can see threads of this like we've
built an open-source documentation
website that ships with DBT where you
type DBT Doc's generate DBT Doc's serve
and you get a web page it's like a
static website it shows all of the
models in your data warehouse and
documentation about you know the tables
and columns and things like that so it's
kind of an early start but it's a super
aligned with our vision of the future
which is like yeah creating tables is
great and really helpful but people need
to know what data exists is is the
quality of the stuff like do our
assumptions about the data hold how
recent is it are people using it things
like that and those are really the big
questions we're interesting in answering
and I think that it's a deep well like
the version of DBT that exists today I
think a lot of people credit with
bringing this organization to their
companies where actually people can look
at it in a warehouse and see like okay I
know what the Goldstar data is I know
where to find the definition of a user
or where to find the definition of an
order which is not always an easy thing
to do and sort of the next iterations of
our vision will have us building tooling
to help these analytes engineers push
the data out to more people and make
sure that folks understand where their
data is coming from like what's the
provenance how reason is it kind of
trust it and kind of close close the
loop like we joke a little bit about I
think up months and does this but like
it's an NPS score for your data set like
I would recommend this data set to a
friend or colleague I think is really
funny but a good idea it's like it's not
a one-way street we need to figure out a
way to get the data to the consumers and
then have the consumers kind of loop
back around and say like yes this was
valuable more of this
like this didn't answer my question
here's what I need instead it's just not
a from what we see a super strong bond
that exists in most organizations and
that's you know part of the fish' - so
you mentioned the analytics engineer
again and francisco is asking in the
chat is analytics engineer just to be
bette rebranding for a bi engineer
what's the difference between the two
good question you know there's a lot of
titles out there this is a rebrand of bi
engineer I think they're more similar
than they are different if if there's
any meaningful distinction
it's that analytics engineers own more
than just the BI piece of it it's like
they are responsible for you know folk
we see a lot of companies switching to
using data warehouses like modern data
warehouses as a single source of truth
for their entire business and they break
down silos and you hear these words on
sales calls with data warehouse better
sometimes and the idea is that if your
goal is to put all of the information
about your business into a data
warehouse then the curators of that data
warehouse are like the librarians for
your company and we think of the
analytics engineer almost as you know
the librarians of the data making it
like addressable and accessible and
documented attested so not that
librarians do a lot of testing but yes
okay so it's not a meaningful
distinction did bi engineers do that
previously yeah I'm sure
the maybe thing I could say is it seems
like folks the title analytics engineer
feels a lot more resonant for people
doing this work but I think bi engineer
does because it's a lot more than just
bi and so along along with that the
suite of features that DVT sports
testing documentation data quality etc
it seems to me like you're
to usher in parallel concepts from the
software engineering world into the
analytics engineering world is that is
that part of your mission do you feel
like this is this is part of the purpose
of DBT and how do you how would you
articulate that yeah so you it's funny
because I I talked about this a little
bit differently depending on the
audience and and maybe for this
technical audience I'll call it how it
is we we very much let me say it this
way analytics for a long time was the
Wild West where folks were just like
making it work and you you did get these
like thousand lines of sequel statements
with nested sub queries and set of
nested sub queries and somebody left the
company and nobody knew how the table
got there that powers all the reporting
and our inspiration was just like well
sequel is code and there exists modern
practices modern best practices for how
to manage the creation and modification
of code and so how many of those ideas
can we take from software engineering
and apply them to analytics and that
gets us things like you know version
control code review automated testing
sort of like a separation of development
staging in production environments and
there are sort of ways to do all of
those things using DBT it's a framework
that is supportive of a modern software
engineering workflow and you know the
piece I said the beginning about calling
how it is calling it how it is
you know I follow a lot of what I would
consider pretty wise seasoned software
engineers and I think if you asked them
has software engineering answered all
the questions about how to build
software they would say like no we have
so much work to do as an industry to
actually build the good tooling and
these are all the problems and here's
what gonna fix so you know for this
audience I just want to claim like a lot
of our inspiration comes from software
engineering but we also recognize that
it's still a developing topic like the
best way to write software it's not
solve problem and this thing is very
much true in the analytic space we just
think it's a good starting point so in
terms of the greater data tooling
ecosystem we already touched on other
projects like like great expectations
are there some other tools
mentioned airflo previously are there
tools that you play nicely with that you
see commonly deployed surrounding or
next to DBT yeah
sure there's you know we we receive a
lot of questions about air flow like
this DBT replace air flow and for us you
know we feel that focus is kind of one
of the key features of DBT so DBT works
super well with air flow
I think it's cool because I love DAGs
and I love the idea of this sort of like
fractal dagger you have air flow that
you know spreads out and do your DBT dag
of transformations and you kind of let
each tool doing something for what it's
good at so we work super well with air
flow there's a lot of folks to playing
DBT as an air flow job we increasingly
are seeing more of tools like gangster
and prefect who I think are sort of like
maybe we can say iterations on the air
flow theme and that's who super
promising as well there's really cool
things that you can do about those
platforms Nix rock in particular I think
gave a great talk in every some data
Council but that I really liked and
we're some of the tools yeah great
expectations was thrown around we you
know DBT is an open source tool it's
beginnings were on the command line
these days we have you know web
interface to that you can use but still
today you can pip install DBT type DPC
run on the command line and get going
and you were inspired by things like the
UNIX philosophy like do one thing to do
it well and make sure that your
composable composable and so we try to
give good interfaces for people to tap
into where we don't need like a
first-class integration with air flow to
be useful like there's a way to address
DBT from air flow and that really opens
up the universe of you know people with
their existing tooling but it's like
Jenkins or airflow err it's kind of
cooling you can still use DBT well I'm
part of this is because of the
flexibility of DBT command-line tool
right this was the origin of DBT was at
the command line and so it seems like
that did allow DBT to get integrated
into
various types and steps of pipelines and
transformations so it sounds like you're
continuing to see that kind of adoption
as well yeah very much so
you know there there's a question you
asked earlier that this kind of reminds
me of which is how do how do different
folks in turn Orca is it in an
organization like work with DBT and so
you you do have say data engineers who
might be pretty happy on the command
line you might also have analysts that
are newer to Python environment
management and running things in the
command line and setting up their text
editors and we're really cool things
about DBT is we've given folks ways to
either write your models on the command
line or in the browser on DBT clobber
just a host product that kind of sits
around DBT and the neat thing is you can
write the code wherever you want but you
can still have the same conversation
with with people that are sort of
operating one environment or another and
you can have a conversation about you
know the data models that you're writing
at a pull request on github regardless
of leg where you're actually writing the
code so we really do try to address both
more engineering more you know people
with an engineering background for some
people with a non engineering background
making sure that as long as you can like
type sequel and kind of breathe through
the DBT documentation you can hit the
ground running with DBT so talk to us a
little bit more about DBT cloud because
that's a newer thing to me that I know
is is one your newer products built
around the DBT core what are the other
benefits of cloud and how does that
affect the way an organization uses DBT
yeah so there are a bunch of open source
companies out there and everyone kind of
takes a different approach on how they
you know have a company that needs to
fade bill as well so like promoting the
development and growth focus for
software and we laid it on a way we call
loose open core model where DBT core
itself the open source thing is fully
capable and can you know connect to
different data bases and issue
transformations and
does everything you need to do for DBT
score value problem
DBT cloud then sits around it and it's
sort of two or three big things one of
them is job scheduler so say you know
there are a lot of folks out there that
are analyst teams of one at an
organization and it would be too much
for them to like set up air flow and
monitoring and collecting logs and
things like that kind of all by
themselves but they really want to do is
start making data models and start
building dashboards and start helping
the folks in their company so DBT clouds
a super easy way to kind of stand up a
scheduled route of DBT it'll you know
clone your repo execute DBT on the
schedule show you the logs and
notifications if like a run fails or if
a test fails that's when that's kind of
one half of DBT cloud the other big half
is a development environment so we find
that DBT is also super useful not only
at companies one analyst but like dozens
and dozens are you know hundreds of
analysts and we find that there's a lot
of heterogeneity and yeah that's third
one and the skill sets of these folks
and so they're people who are really
happy on the command line there are
people who it's it's too abrupt a change
to say okay you want to build a data
model fix your Python environment figure
out how to pit stall DBT on Windows
which is can't be tough these days and
then muck with some credentials in your
and a hidden folder in your home
directory and then learn how do you
navigate the command line like CD and
Alice you know these are good skills we
think folks should learn them if they're
gonna do significant you know code
development which we think building a
DBT project is but it's a little bit too
much to ask folks to do upfront and so
what we're trying to do with the DBT IDE
is build sort of like a sensible upgrade
path where you can pop into a web
browser start building data models you
know run run them build things in your
development environment click around
them see what happens it's like a built
in git workflow so you can do a real
version control flow and you know over
time we hope that the idea is compelling
enough that folks will like really enjoy
it in the native DBT integration and the
UX that comes with it but we also
like we think local development awesome
that's why we set out to build a
command-line tool that you know the
primary interface is like for me vim for
my colleagues like Adam or vs code I you
know I would never hold that against
someone if they say I want to take the
next step and I've learned vim well I
would hold that against some people you
shouldn't do it with 20/20 just kidding
so yeah yes yeah yeah so um on that note
I just want to highlight for the
community that in case you haven't used
EBT and read can explain more but
there's a whole set of there's a
templating language which I believe is
based in on ginger correct yeah that's
right um there's a template language
there's variable support there's package
support so I think this is one of the
most appealing things about DBT to the
early users was that it gave you a way
to uniformly parameterize your sequel
and turn it into control flow structures
without needing to use proprietary
pl/sql or some other transact-sql
variant baked into that was tightly
coupled with a particular Artyom PMS so
true I assume that's been like one of
the huge leverage points around writing
your code in DBT slot DBT templates with
SQL and inside them is the ability to
really for a program or type to feel
like they got leverage over traditional
programming structures yeah so it's a
powerful tool that folks must wield
responsibly so you're totally right DBT
ships with the ginger the templating
language it is staggering how similar
building out sequel statements feels to
building out websites where you've got
some components you want to reuse kind
of all over the place or where you kind
of want to do basically the same thing
twelve times but with slightly different
semantics and so DB T's Jinja support is
specific to kind of rendering or what we
would say compiling a sequel statement
that runs again
the database so maybe you want to just
say you often you want to like pivot out
a table so like show me the account
where this column had this value and
you've got a hundred different value so
when a pivot outs 100 different columns
so you can write all that by hand you
could use say you know store procedures
or database specific functionality or
you could do it with DBT and so we can
kind of do is like write a for loop that
will loop over an array of 100 values
and you can say sum of case when value
equals the first thing one else zero and
you're you're sort of writing the script
that generates the code that DBT will
actually write against the database so
it's a really powerful thing we find
that you know folks when they have that
ability for the first time they sort of
have a tendency to over template things
and never repeat the same line of code
twice like macro eyes everything so you
know we we think a lot about finding
ways to keep code so you keep code dry
like don't repeat yourself but also
acknowledge that sometimes repeating
things isn't the worst thing if it's a
little bit more readable so just the
other one of those cases where it's like
a powerful tool and sort of up to the
implementer to decide what the right way
to employ it is so cou stuff has a
question about gin Chuck he's commenting
that ginger compiles the template string
compile time but they're wondering is
there any plan to introduce write
templates for runtime execution instead
you stop I'm unsure that I understand
what what you're thinking here it's a
neat question right Pete do you know it
may be what Cousteau may be thinking it
might I might be being uh well I know
that DBT has this notion of compiling
SQL but I'm not a deep user of the
product so I'd have to explain what that
really means more okay so great on he's
right
a DBT does kind of look like a more
standard compiler it takes a sort of
like parsing pass where it looks at all
the files in a DBT project it parses out
the representation and sort of the
dependencies between different notes in
the dag and also any configuration that
you apply so like create this model in
the database as a viewer a table sort of
a parsing step then we do a bit of like
what I think of as a linking step where
it's like okay actually build out the
dag of how these things relate to each
other and validate it make sure there
are no cycles or no references to things
that are not defined and there's sort of
a runtime step and that runtime step is
where DBT starts at the roots of the dag
and just kind of executes its things as
it goes in parallel so you know my key
question here is like I don't totally
understand the runtime execution piece
because DBT does sort of in fact take
another pass at runtime where it will
actually generate the sequel that gets
run so the interesting thing is like
your DP sees that compiler when it's
parsing out a model so you've got a
hundred models and you're looking at the
first one and your first one reference
is a model that you haven't parsed yet
well you can capture the reference but
you actually don't know and maybe this
would make more sense for the code but
for any DB users out there you don't
know what the Rev al you eighths to at
parse time because you haven't parsed
all the nodes yet so every one time we
re execute the template we have full
information of the dag and we can render
out exactly the sequel that you want
instead of just like capturing your
intentions and holding on to it for
later so I get to past got it that's
super helpful
um Gustav is also asking about the plan
to introduce adaptors for other
databases and someone jumped on and
asked for Athena yeah I mean I've got
good news
we built DBT with a database plug-in
architecture if you actually follow the
when I think of it I'm like is
archaeology you could like look through
the code and get hints of like
civilization civilization pass
we we built DBT initially it only
supported redshift we voyeur what a
death it's for for snowflake and we were
like well we can decide there are two
databases of DBT supports or we could
make it a sort of plug-in system where
you can just move an interface for
connect to a new database and so today
DBT ships with support for Postgres
redshift snowflake and bigquery but
there are kind of external plugins that
live in their own repos some maintained
by us some not for you know presto spark
very much Athena under active
development there too sequel server
plugins we've heard about a vertical one
and someone's working like a green plum
is that a database I think based on post
press so if you could if you can run
sequel against the database and execute
like create table and create these
statements
you could build a DBT plugin for it and
there is very much for the you know one
out there if you joined the DBT slack at
community dot get DBT comm you can hop
into the DBT of the Athena Channel and
talk with the maintainers awesome I
wanted to make sure that we covered that
specifically how folks can join the DBT
community we have another question about
someone asking about setup on Windows
and it sounds to me like something maybe
we shouldn't dig into here directly but
I'm sure someone on the DBT slack would
be able to help so that's to community
DBT comm true yeah community dot get DBT
calm doc get DBT calm great Oh always
for the windows question I won't hide
from it all right
you know we we love Python and Python
and our experience and opinion is the
programming language the D programming
language for data
I think article two but we don't see the
wealth and the ecosystem around it quite
like we do in Python for like maybe data
engineering specific stuff and one of
the really tough things about Python is
that packaging and distribution are like
not self problems today we've kind of
worked towards a better solution on Mac
where we use make like homebrew
distributions that help a little bit but
on Windows you're still pip installing
and Python doesn't make it easy to do a
good job so we're happy to help you with
your specific problem in the slack and
we remain interested in other
distribution mechanisms like I don't
even know enough to say but I think I
heard about a tool called chocolaty once
that could be relevant a little bit too
hard to install DBT on windows today
we'd like to fix that No
well we're almost out of time I wanted
to ask you a little bit about the future
Dru and what are some upcoming features
about DBT that you're particularly
excited about yeah the the central data
structure in DBT is the dag
of all your models and behind the scenes
the way DBT represents your dag is you
sort of have data models that depend on
your data sources and you have tests
that depend on the models and there are
other ways that we sort of a know tape
this dag with really helpful information
and so some of the stuff we're working
on next is giving more powerful tooling
around operating on that dag so for
instance today you can say you know I
just got a new load of Salesforce data
run all of my models to depend on
Salesforce and everything downstream of
them but in the future and one of things
working on now is supporting like kind
of graph set intersection so you can say
run all of my models that depend on
Salesforce and are tagged with the
hourly tag it's like not a thing that
you could do before in it they're really
specific to use cases that are super
powerful that we kind of unlock by
supporting this beyond that and maybe we
don't have quite enough time to dig all
the way in but I'll be real quick about
it
there's you know DBT has a different
notion of different environments so you
could have a development environment
kind of staging environment a production
environment it means different things on
different databases but just imagine
like you've got a different schema where
you build all of your transformations
into
for me it's called DBT true Pete Frio
become DBT P in production maybe you
call prod it means that you can sort of
test out new models by building the
material sandbox schema without stomping
all over production you don't get a
multiple copies the entire Navy Beatty
project in the database and one of the
really cool things is because every DBT
model is a definite and graph aware when
you open a pull request in github gitlab
you can automate the creation of a new
schema that's like identified for that
PR and you can build all of your DVT
models into it and then you can run all
of your assertions and make sure the
tests pass so this gives you like a
little check mark and the pull request
and you can do this in DBT cloud today
but it's kind of a missing piece which
is that right now DBT needs to run the
entirety of your dag in order to tell
you that like the one file that you
changed succeeded or failed and so one
of the things that's coming to as a part
of this initiative is kind of smarter we
call note selectors from the graph so
you can say I want to run my DBT project
but only the models that are new or
changed since the last time I ran DBT
and everything downstream of them plus
their tests and then you can do that
with intersections so it's like right
now everything that's changed it's also
not tagged with the that's actually set
difference say not tagged with like
don't run in CI or something like that
just like more powerful tooling for
development and deployment of DBT neat
that sounds super compelling look out
airflow you know they work well together
awesome well lastly you guys just raised
a bunch of money so congratulations on
that I know that your team is growing so
where can folks who are interested in
potentially working with DBT on Fishtown
I'll find you yeah right on we're one of
those companies that has a different
name from our product so the company
website is Fishtown analytics comm the
background is that Fishtown is the
neighborhood in Philadelphia where we
started the company and
the thing I'm hesitating to say is like
we would ever quite a fish town we were
across the street but pretty close close
enough and you wouldn't know how to feel
about Sun filling so fish toenail is
calm there's a link to the jobs page you
can check out like our mission and
values were a strongly mission driven
company and in particular if you're
interested in maybe work with us on what
we're building check out our values and
see if they resonate with you we care a
lot about creating more value than you
capture and moving up the stack awesome
well drew thanks for being a member of
the data Council community for all these
years it's been really great to have you
and thanks for joining us on the show
today it's been super helpful for the
community and they're all appreciative
as well yeah thanks a lot Peter it's
truly my pleasure thank you